after a bunch of back-and-forth Donald
Trump is not going to be giving the
State of the Union address on Tuesday
January 29th in the House of
Representatives and it is absolutely
delightful Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi has succeeded in explaining to
Donald Trump that ultimately it's up to
her whether he gives the speech in the
House of Representatives or not and
Donald Trump has conceded this will get
to his tweets a little bit later but let
me catch you up on the entire
back-and-forth
it started with Nancy Pelosi sending an
invitation letter to Donald Trump to
come and give the State of the Union
address and this is sort of a formality
but it's also sort of not a formality
because the Speaker of the House does
have to invite from to speak before a
joint session of Congress the president
can't just decide that he is going to
speak on the floor of the House of
Representatives the president I believe
has floor privileges at the US Senate
which means he can get on the floor of
the US Senate but that doesn't mean that
he can just choose to speak there if not
invited and certainly he can't choose to
speak on the floor of the House of
Representatives either so initially
Nancy Pelosi invited Trump then the
shutdown happened and Nancy Pelosi sent
a letter sort of suggesting that it be
postponed over security concerns because
the federal government's partially shut
down these are these special national
security events and we were sort of
reading between the lines she's just
saying if the government shutdown were
not letting you speak but at least
security was what was cited and remember
that the State of the Union can be given
from anywhere the Constitution says only
that it needs to take place from time to
time often it used to be done in writing
so there's nothing that says it has to
be at the House of Representatives it
has to be in January or February it
usually is but it certainly doesn't have
to be so Donald Trump I guess thought he
was being brilliant by writing a letter
back to Nancy Pelosi saying I asked
about the security Security's going to
be fine so I still plan on speaking and
sort of calling Nancy Pelosi's Bluff and
then Nancy Pelosi just wrote back saying
no she wrote back yesterday saying I'm
writing to inform you that the House of
Representatives will not consider a
concurrent resolution authorizing the
president's State of the Union in the
House chamber until the government has
reopened
I support her in this I think that this
is great that she's number one not
letting Donald Trump push her around
given Trump's views on women and his
views on his own sort of alpha male
status he is clearly triggered by
potentially not getting his way he wants
to force his way into the House of
Representatives and she's not going to
let him do it and all along this process
he seemed not to understand that it's
just not up to him and now he finally
does understand it he's the president he
doesn't own everything he's not used to
being told no he's certainly not used to
women telling him no and he doesn't want
to seem like a loser but he is accepting
that he is not going to be allowed to
give the State of the Union address and
one of the most important reasons I mean
listen there are these sort of
personality dynamics we don't want to
give Trump the idea that he's in charge
of stuff he's not in charge of and all
of that I don't want him spending an
hour or an hour and 15 minutes or 45
minutes or however many minutes it is
doing a build the wall rally we just
don't need that okay we just don't need
the State of the Union address at all
really I mean government's been shut
down for more than a month were the
world's laughingstock that's the State
of the Union and Donald Trump has
accepted this Donald from taking to
Twitter late last night and tweeting as
the shutdown was going on Nancy Pelosi
asked me to give the State of the Union
address I agreed she then changed her
mind because of the shutdown suggesting
a later date this is her prerogative
that's right I will do the address when
the shutdown is over I am NOT looking
for an alternative venue for the State
of the Union address because there is no
venue that can compete with the history
tradition and importance of the House
chamber I look forward to giving a quote
great State of the Union address in the
near future Pat you know that this is
not how Donald Trump talks this is not
how Donald Trump behaves this is a Trump
who is pretending to play nice because
he's been told by advisers you can't win
this stop fighting it
try to save face he lost Nancy Pelosi
won and I say good for her yeah total
surrender here I thought he would take
his ball and go home I thought maybe he
would deliver the address for
the Oval Office or just somewhere in the
white house or maybe he would hold a
campaign rally and do it there but no I
guess he wants to wait around and I
think this is the right decision even if
it takes another month or two before the
government reopens
what's also funny about all of this is
that anyone who understands how this
works knew that Pelosi would win on this
one and in particular anybody who's been
following how Nancy Pelosi hasn't been
pushed around she hasn't been bullied by
Donald Trump into reopening government
with money for the border wall she is
standing clear and saying this is your
shutdown we said before we weren't going
to give you money for the wall we are
still saying now we're not giving you
money for the wall this is your shutdown
and you own it if we saw her behavior
there of not being pushed around of
course she wasn't going to be pushed
around into letting Trump speak if she
doesn't want him to speak while the
shutdown is going on and you know he has
this reputation that is it's sort of an
apocryphal reputation for being a great
master negotiator he seems to have
negotiated himself out of his position
from yesterday morning to this new one
where he's saying Nancy Pelosi wins
Nancy Pelosi gets her way and we will
see how he ultimately negotiates him
himself out of his own shutdown that was
totally optional I look forward to that
the only downside is now we won't have a
State of the Union livestream on Tuesday
which I was sort of looking looking
forward to doing but I have a feeling
before it's all said and done before the
year is out anyway we will probably get
something that we can approximately call
a State of the Union address from Donald
Trump to analyze one of the day's
sponsors is privacy dot-com / Pakman
which is a free service that I myself
use really useful in many different ways
takes just a few seconds to link your
debit card to privacy calm then you can
create virtual credit cards that are
linked directly to your bank account and
you use those virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use
let's say for example that I'm signing
up for a david pakman show membership in
the credit card number field I already
see the privacy comm icon I just click
it choose which of my virtual credit
cards I want to use and the credit card
number expiration date and security code
are automatically entered I can put in
any zip code I want and I'm done and if
you try to use my credit card number
that you just saw on the screen it
doesn't matter because I've already
deleted that virtual card and that's the
beauty of privacy calm there are a ton
of advantages to using a free service
like this for example you can sign up
for as many free trials as you want then
just delete the virtual credit card you
used and never worry about getting
charged for it it protects you from
getting hacked it protects you when
companies are hacked which happens all
the time it is all completely free all
you have to do is click the link under
this video to get started and for a
limited time they're giving everyone in
our audience $5 towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link